aquí
más de 5 horas de reunión entre el
presidente francés emmanuel majo y su
homólogo vladimir putin en un nuevo
intento para desescalar las tensiones
entre rusia y ucrania les contamos las
conclusiones
como parte de los frenéticos esfuerzos
para ponerle fin a la crisis del
presidente joe biden se reunió en
washington con el canciller alemán olaf
scholz bailén dijo que el gasoducto ruso
nord swing 2 debe cancelarse si hay una
invasión rusa a ucraniano analizamos en
esta emisión
y se solucionó la crisis política en el
congreso de honduras los diputados
disidentes que habían elegido a otro
presidente del legislativo respaldaron
la junta directiva de la mandataria
xiomara castró los detalles desde
tegucigalpa
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 mi nombre es
maría clara calle y es un placer estar
con ustedes y comenzamos hablando del
presidente francés emmanuel bach o quien
afirmó que hubo puntos de convergencia
en la reunión de hoy en moscú con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin en la que
discutieron la atención por el
despliegue de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania mientras que el
líder del kremlin dijo que espera que la
situación se resuelva pacíficamente pero
advirtió que si la otan acepta a ucrania
como uno de sus miembros los países
europeos serán arrastrados a una guerra
con moscú escuchemos lo que dijeron
estamos en contra de la ampliación de la
otan con los dos miembros hacia el este
primero porque esto nos plantea la
amenaza de la ampliación continua de lo
de la otan hacia nuestras fronteras
son los estados de la otan los que se
están acercando a rusia no somos
nosotros los que estamos yendo hacia la
frontera sobre construir juntos
respetando nuestros fundamentos
garantías concretas de seguridad para
los estados miembros de la unión europea
para los estados de la región
ucrania georgia belarús y para rusia es
exactamente la ambición que debemos
perseguir la ambición club de boxeo para
hablar más de este encuentro entre
macrón y putin conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal
xavier colás quien está en ucrania
xavier buenas noches y cuéntanos más de
cinco horas de reunión cuál es la
conclusión y las acciones concretas con
miras a la des escalada de las tensiones
pues la conclusión es que la diplomacia
aunque ha conseguido pocos frutos hasta
ahora va a seguir avanzando y de momento
a seguir siendo la primera opción la
guerra en ucrania de momento no va a
empezar mañana vladimir putin aunque ha
mostrado pocos puntos de convergencia
con el mono el macro sí que sí que ha
dicho que hay una base para seguir
trabajando sobre algunas de las
propuestas que le ha hecho esta noche el
presidente francés también putin ha
hablado de las propuestas
norteamericanas y de la otan recordemos
que moscú había recibido ya esa oferta a
sus propuestas de seguridad y ha dicho
que va a contestar así que nos esperan
todavía unos cuantos días en los que los
políticos van a seguir dialogando lo que
queda por ver es lo que van a conseguir
vladimir putin también ha explicado hoy
cuáles son sus miedos sus preocupaciones
respecto a la entrada de ucrania en la
otan ha recordado que ucrania ir a
recuperar la península de crimea
carrosse se anexionó y esto según
vladímir putin podría conducir en un
futuro a que si ucrania forma parte de
la otan la otra se ve arrastrada a una
guerra con rusia el presidente macro les
ha mostrado a pesar de todo optimista ha
dicho que hay que seguir dialogando que
hay que crear una estructura europea de
seguridad para que esta crisis tenga una
salida pacífica gracias javier por este
reporte y mientras marco me puteen se
reunían en moscú el canciller alemán
olaf scholz viajó a washington para
mostrar una postura conjunta ante rusia
el tema de tensiones el gasoducto nord
stream 2 que duplicaría la cantidad de
gas que moscú le provee a alemania el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
reiteró que si hay un conflicto con
moscú este proyecto se tiene que acabar
pero souls no confirmó la cancelación
sin embargo si reiteró que su país se
une a las sanciones que eeuu ha
prometido contra rusia
y
así rusia invade eso significa que
tanques o tropas crucen la frontera de
ucrania
entonces no habrá north stream 2
[Música]
como ya dije estamos actuando juntos
estamos absolutamente unidos y no
tomaremos pasos diferentes y haremos los
mismos pasos y serán muy duros contra
rusia para entender un poco más el
alcance de los encuentros diplomáticos
de hoy conectamos con víctor mijares
profesor coordinador de la maestría en
estudios internacionales de la
universidad de los andes en colombia
señor mijares bienvenido a france 24 y
comencemos hablando de qué tan efectiva
fue la reunión entre el presidente
francés emmanuel marco y su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin hay conclusiones o
son sólo encuentros sin resultados con
acciones concretas
o lo abrazaron esto creo que es muy
prematuro para hablar de conclusiones
sin embargo también creo que es
importante este tipo de encuentros
francia es una potencia que al igual que
rusia tiene un temor y es el temor de la
irrelevancia internacional y en ese
sentido se entienden bastante bien y
además de eso francia tiene una posición
muy importante en el consejo de
seguridad en la otan con una potencia
nuclear y algo muy importante que no
tiene por ejemplo alemania tiene una
cierta autonomía con respecto al gas
ruso y eso le permite ser un
interlocutor válido por eso creo que
estas negociaciones estos diarios rusos
franceses van a continuar y quizás sean
el mecanismo más idóneo en este momento
para escalar más grises y hablamos ahora
de alemania que usted lo mencionó porque
el encuentro entre bailén y el canciller
alemán olaf scholz no trajo acuerdos
sobre cómo reaccionar frente al
gasoducto nord swing 2 no es lo
suficientemente firme la postura alemana
frente a las tensiones entre rusia y
ucrania como lo dicen los críticos del
gobierno alemán
es que no puede ser su suficientemente
firme por una razón elemental de
seguridad energética alemania depende en
casi tres cuartas partes de su consumo
eléctrico de energía fósil de
combustibles fósiles y más de un tercio
de esos combustibles fósiles vienen
precisamente de la natural y el gran
proveedor de gas natural de alemania es
precisamente rusia si en alemania
renuncias a esa fuente de energía podría
entrar en una situación de inseguridad
energética e incluso lesionar sus
propios intereses económicos es por eso
que no vamos a ver al menos abiertamente
ninguna forma de apoyo del canciller
todos a este tipo de medidas porque en
definitiva va en contra los intereses
energéticos de alemania que además forma
parte de una matriz energética y una
decisión que tuvo de marjah de su crisis
a su sistema lente
sí y del otro lado que tanto poder tiene
eeuu realmente para cancelarnos nor
swing 2 en caso tal de que alemania y
rusia lo quieran sacar adelante
es muy difícil que esto suceda porque
eso se parte tanto de la seguridad
energética y financiera de rusia como de
alemania en ese sentido creo que trata
el presidente by de de arrastrar un poco
aica sirios a su propia línea de
política exterior sus tiempos sumarlo a
su posición de dura frente a rusia pero
la emoción de los hados eeuu puede ser
muy dura frente a rusia pero no tanto la
de alemania por un elemento diego pasos
confunden ventaja en la geografía para
los eeuu no hay un daño importante a su
economía pero para la imagen será
catastrófico gracias víctor mijares por
estar con nosotros y terminamos con
noticias latinoamericanas en honduras ya
hay una única junta directiva del
congreso después de dos semanas en las
que 17 diputados disidentes no apoyaron
al presidente del congreso que respaldó
la mandataria xiomara castró nuestra
corresponsal en tegucigalpa kenia torres
tiene los detalles
la profunda crisis interna en el
congreso hondureño en el que dos juntas
directivas se disputaban el control del
mismo ha llegado este día a su fin con
la firma de un acuerdo histórico entre
el presidente del partido libertad y
refundación de la mandataria xiomara
castró y un grupo de diputados
disidentes del mismo partido encabezados
por jorge cálix quien este día se ha
comprometido a apoyar la decisión de la
mandataria y su junta directiva
propuesta encabezada por el
parlamentario luis redondo con esto se
pone fin a esta crisis que mantenía esos
obras la gobernabilidad del país y que
impedían que castró llevara a cabo su
agenda legislativa encaminada a una
lucha frontal contra la corrupción y a
buscar soluciones a los profundos
problemas estructurales del país como la
pobreza la migración y los serios
problemas en materia de educación y
salud aunque el acuerdo se llevó a cabo
presidencial no estuvo la mandataria ya
que ella misma confirmó a través de sus
redes sociales que se encuentra positiva
por kobe de 19 estados de salud es
estable
y antes de terminar nuestra emisión los
invitamos a que consulten nuestra página
web france24 puntocom como lo vemos en
este momento tenemos abriendo la nota
sobre macrón que urge a putin una
solución útil a la atención con ucrania
para evitar una guerra
y sigan conectados las 24 horas a la
señal de france 24 nos vemos para más
información en minutos
[Música]